thank you very much
hi and welcome
my name is jonathan
if you have any questions afterwards
feel free to catch me outside in the
discord via email on twitter whatever
i'm working for scalable minds we are a
small software company in potsdam close
to berlin
and i'm just want to explain some parts
of my domain why i want to speak about
the speed ups and why this actually was
quite important for us
so we've built webnozzles webnoses is a
3d viewer and annotation tool for
3d image data
so here you can see some
electron microscopy data of brain tissue
um and
what we are doing besides that is also
the analysis of those segments so we're
tracing which part is a cell
in the brain tissue and this is what's
colored here in the picture
if you want to see some of those cool
data sets
that biological researchers acquired you
can check out webnoses.org
we also built a python library to
interact with it that's a webinar source
pi
and you can just do pip install
webmasters to try it yourself
this is all also open source
so
when we are doing data analysis on those
data sets
we're speaking about petabyte scale
image data sets so the resolution of
those data sets is in the nanometer
scheme so
there's quite a lot of data we're just
handling
then we have some machine learning
systems that we train on this data and
run on it
and we have some post-processing steps
on this
so we do segmentation based on the
predictions we get from our machine
learning systems and we do agglomeration
so we can trace longer cells especially
because the neurons have very thin
processes that's quite hard to track
and what we get out basically is those
neuron reconstructions where we can see
a cell
and not just one cell but possibly all
of the cells in the volume and where
they connect where the interactions are
the synapses of the neurons so that the
biological researchers can do the
biological research in the end and not
the boring data analysis
and
those experiments are running for weeks
or even months in high performance
computing clusters
so that's just to give a bit of a
context where actually the problem
we encounter are coming from
so
we're talking about speed ups with data
analysis so why to speed up
um when it's slow
and especially it's important
that you speed up then and also it's
important not to over optimize
everything beforehand which i know many
of us are prone to um
and i think it's all fair if it's
totally working to hack something
and if the data grows
then it's getting too slow then you can
tune it even more and that's actually
what we did
so here's an example of one of the
problems we encountered
so
we had a pipeline running
and where we combine statistics of those
segments
of chunk data sets so
we have the brain tissue we chunk it
into smaller parts and we gather
statistics for those cells
in those chunks
and afterwards we want to combine them
across the different chunks
and after the data grew even more it
just couldn't run at all anymore because
it crashed without of memory
after two days running um and while the
machine was having a terabyte of memory
so that's quite annoying we thought well
that cannot possibly be good let's do
something
and then we did some optimizations
brought it down to 18 hours and then for
even after some more optimizations down
to seven hours and that's quite
important because
when we do the experiments
now they run first and we can do more
iterations per week when we try
different combinations of parameters
that was really important so we had a
speed up of something 500 to 700 percent
in total for this single analysis step
and i've prepared a toy example where we
will see
all the effects we did there just in a
really small example and we will have a
speed up of roughly 200
there but it's quite comparable if the
data just grows and it's
also a 2d example and not 3d then this
will be similar
so the example you can see here on the
top right
there we have
chunked segments so all of the circles
are different segments and in this case
the static statistics are really simple
we just look at the center
of all of the different segments and the
size or the volume of the segments
and we have this per chunk and we want
to combine it across all the chunks so
that we have a single center per segment
and the volume of the segment the volume
is just denoted by the size of the
circle here
yeah
so
that's about
why we would speed up
why should we speed up on a single core
because that's somehow the title of the
presentation right
so
there are some
parts where you want to paralyze soon
but think first maybe about if you want
to paralyze if it pays off
um
if you can do much more optimization on
a single core first so because every
optimization you do on a single core
usually also pays off afterwards if you
have parallelized it if you have a speed
up on a single core you probably will
have the same speed up also after
parallelization
um parallelization needs resources so
you need to have the course the memory
cluster nodes if you are in high
performance clusters or cloud nodes
it usually costs some money time time to
run time to build it
and some code might just not be easy to
parallelize or it's purely impossible
so
exactly in this example it would be
quite hard to do
more parallelization since we did gather
the statistics per chunk of our data and
we just want to combine it all
afterwards that's not easily
parallelizable
so i brought you five steps
the first one is profiling and i think
that's the most important one where
we'll also spend some more time
then we'll talk about efficient io about
data formats
about vectorization
memory and precision trade-offs
and cheating with number just as a very
last point
so let's have a look at the actual code
so i brought you the notebooks i'm not
doing any live coding i would be too
nervous for that to be honest
so this is just the example i showed you
before so we do some imports
and then we just have some code and we
know well it's a slow we want to
optimize it
and we have some load data code some
combined statistics code
and there's just a call
that calls those both
and
maybe we just have a brief look what
this roughly does
so load data
seems to take a couple of json files
and
has some lists
and then just takes the data of the json
files and appends it okay
and combine statistics
okay
there something happens
let's see later what it exactly does we
don't need to know for sure right now
um
and then
center is somewhere multiplied with a
count okay that might make sense because
smaller segments need to have a
different weight when combining the
centers
and
there we return the results for the
different things okay but that's just
somebody wrote it we want to optimize it
just skim through it no deep
understanding yet totally fine
so we run it
and
i have this handy plot function
seems like it does what it should be
doing
so
now we want to profile it where are the
bottlenecks and i think that's the most
important part you can optimize many
things about this code and you could
dive in and think oh that seems to be
too slow
but let's check actually first what are
the slow parts
so
what we could do
is run time it that's built in in the
tupider or you can also use directly
with python
and
i have prepared this large data set as
well so this one was just a small sample
okay and this seems to take like
15 seconds more or less okay interesting
now we know the time but let's get into
the details so there are multiple
profilers in python and i'm going to
show you two here exactly one is yappy
yet another python profiler i think
something similar
and
okay we can either measure cpu time or
wall clock time
and we start yappy
and we just call the function we're
interested in
yep stop
and print the results
then we can see here how often
a specific method or function was called
right
and the thing is that yappy is
instrumenting all of our code
to exactly get those information and get
the statistics up for it and this just
takes time which is problematic so if
you have lots of calling functions like
here some things are called 10 000 times
um that actually might be a problem
because
the profiler is just slowing down
everything and also just giving
different results since
those are instrumented much more often
than others
so
another profiler i quite like
that's too long
is pi spy
pi spy has the nice property that it's
sampling based
and it's just attaching to the python
process you're running
you can also just if you use a python
script do pi spy and run your python
script afterwards or you just attach to
a running process
by getting the process id here
and just attaching this so this is just
a shell script basically what we're
doing here
we are opening a sub process
starting pi spy to watch exactly on the
thing that is currently running
and gather the statistics there
and this is much more efficient we still
have a slowdown to roughly 20 seconds
something like this
but since it's just sampling from the
outside and also it's
really
about efficiency here i think pi spy is
written in rust and just attaching to
the process from the outside
so we don't have that much deviation
from the actual runs
i've configured some more things here so
we can also check native code if we have
native extensions see extensions rust
extensions whatever
we can also watch subprocessors
that's just showing how everything is
grouped later in the graph
and we have an output that is a flame
graph in this case so pi spy can do chop
like outputs if you know what that is um
also different things and flame graphs
and let's have a look at it here
maybe like this
yeah
so this is a flame graph
for this program can you read it some or
is it too small
okay
perfect so
here we have lots of calling functions
just from the outside because it's in a
two-parter notebook but we're actually
interested in load and combine stats i
can click on it and just resizes on this
and we can see
combined stats is taking just a little
portion of the time and load data here
seems to be quite a lot
so okay load data definitely seems to be
a bottleneck
and we can also have a look more here
json decode okay that takes quite long
we're actually talking about numbers so
maybe there's something more efficient
than just decoding strings from a json
so with this information we can go on
and
i've written a small decorator here
measure and compare
which does exactly the same we just get
the flame graph afterwards and also it
just gives us the time of the step
so profiling i would say is the most
important of those steps because it
helps you where you want to
go deeper and actually spend time on
optimization
so just a small overview we've looked at
pi spy
it is sampling based we have flame
graphs it can also do speed scopes if
you know what that is there is yappi
that does it line wise c profile is
built in with python it's uh
directly there pi instrument is quite
popular palantir i think rather young i
didn't try it myself but also really
popular
and for memory
memory profiling i usually use memorable
memory profiler or guppy three also
quite popular
um
for
speed
i think except for pi's by all of those
are directly instrumenting your code so
they all suffer from the same downsides
as yappy
so
we've already seen that
data loading seems to be a bottleneck
okay because we're loading lots of json
files so a typical thing is
we write everything as a json or as a
csv or maybe as a yaml if you're into
that and that oftentimes might not scale
i mean we implement it as writing it for
json when the datasets were just
orders of magnitude smaller
and what usually is much more efficient
is directly writing into binary data
format
so there are multiple
hdf5 is quite known also
compatible with other languages there
are many implementations
npi is from numpy directly a format
parket is quite known in
pickle
for python things themselves you can
also use an sqlite database why not or
sar for multi-dimensional arrays
also possible or many others
so
what we did in our case was using hdf5
and
let's have a look
so i also stored all the input chunks
directly as hdf 5 files here just for
the preparation of this talk
and now we're just loading the hdfi
files
still the rest looks pretty similar we
are pending the different segment
numbers counts and centers
and everything else is just the same we
use the same combined stats function as
before
so the result seems to be fine
and we have now
just
much smaller times so this is already 55
percent faster than before
you can have a look at the flame graph
again
so now
load data is still
the majority
but it looks more sane to be honest
also i mean it's still in different
files if we would be able to just
squeeze everything in one single file
that would probably still be much more
efficient i didn't put this in here but
also just iterating across 10 000 files
in this case isn't a good idea so if
you're able to just squeeze everything
in one that's usually more efficient as
well
so the next step
is vectorization
so
now we go from the data loading to
actually the combined
stats parts
so let's have a look at the original
implementation once again
so
what we do here
this is centers per segment
um
and counts per segment
so this might be a group by across the
segments just guessing from the names
and then we go across all segments and
sum up things
okay so
after loading this from hd5 we already
get numpy arrays
why not do the math with numpy as well
let's go down here again
so we just do this
here the group by code is still the same
and
after we did the group by we put
everything in a single array
and use numpy
methods directly so here the sum on this
and
here calculations for the center
and this obviously
is much more efficient already
so the number here is not that much more
impressive but still it gives us a bit
and that's probably what all of you know
already
but the important part is we can also do
the group by with numpy
so
what we are doing here
is we concatenate all the input arrays
directly
and then to do a group by a numpy
we sort all our areas by the segment
numbers
get the first index of the different
segments
and split all the arrays by those
indices
and this directly gives us the different
groups for each segment
so if you want to have a look more
deeply at the code i think you can just
check out the github later um
but this now actually
gives us 100 more
which is crazy
um
so
numpy in comparison to for example just
python this is really compact in the
representation because all of it your
data is just
continuous more or less in memory
and you have optimized functions
directly for those
things
then
maybe for the group buy you think well i
could have done that with pandas as well
yep definitely
but also
for example especially group by with
pandas isn't that fast it is faster than
the python loops we saw before but still
the numpy version is is much faster
there are also
better possibilities that's just the
last row there are so many alternatives
and some of them are quite efficient but
i'd also recommend
if you want to really get down into the
optimization part just sticking to numpy
is also a good case because what can you
do if the group buy is slow
in some library probably not that much
so
if you just use numpy for the different
things you have you can also tune it
much better
than with anything that's just pre-made
next point is memory and precision
trade-offs
so
when we're talking about speed we also
have to talk about memory and precision
so usually we can have some trade-offs
in this triangle for example we can
change the data type and we're just
doing that in a second so
this will take less memory directly but
also the precision will be
less
but
it might just be faster because we're
iterating about smaller portions of data
then there are other things like
iterative methods you can consider
conquer divide and conquer things reduce
this usually also uses smaller memory
but you might
lack numerical precision in the end a
typical example also are lookup tables
or just compression
so when we check this here
this is basically the same code as
before
but we do as type you and 32 for the
segment ids first because they just all
fit into a
20 32 bits before it was 64
and the same for the counts and the
centers
and the rest is totally the same as
before
and we even get 20 more speed up
which is great
and just by reducing the precision which
we don't need we don't need the full
precision at all
so the last point i'll show
is if that is not enough you can use
cheating so so far we've used
number numpy but if you use numpy you
can also consider number with is
cheating your code
and optimizing the different calls
because
for
numpy code
you still have to consider that all the
arrays can be n-dimensional can have
different types they're different checks
and you can just put number engine
here before the n is for the no python
mode so it forces
the cheating that is just all native
code afterwards
and everything is still the same
and we just run it again
we will run into an error
here
okay failed in no python mode
let's see can we find something here
no implementation of function get item
for the signature
okay interesting the slice
so
if we check this again
show it here
so this is just this line
and this just doesn't work with numbers
there are some parts that won't work
that well
and
this is just one of those you will get
different error messages but you can go
through all of those and this will be
fine
so
we fix this by using reshape instead
and then it works
so the first time
we're running it
it will be slower than before because
the cheating itself
takes also the compilation time but the
second time it's a bit faster than
before
and in this example because just
averaging all those centers and the
counts there's not much that number can
speed up
but i've also prepared here a different
example
where we are looking also at the
covariance metrics of those
and
there
after just also using
[Music]
number chit here
now we get five percent more than before
so that's really simple just add number
engine
and you have to fix some errors probably
when you use number but afterwards it
might just be faster
so besides what i've shown you there are
obviously more things so you can upgrade
your dependencies and python itself that
might just be faster afterwards
just check the change logs if that has
something to do with your parts
you can use faster python runtimes if
that's less data centric and more python
loops etc
um you can optimize critical code paths
with something that's closer to the
metal like siphon pipeline 11
cffi for rust there's pio3
i just watched a talk yesterday about
onyx that's why i also put that in here
and
then also you can think about
parallelization but
optimizing your code first on a single
core just pays off afterwards so that's
what i'd recommend the most important
thing for you to take away is just do
profiling look where is the bottleneck
and then
you have more steps how to optimize it
thanks a lot and you can find
[Applause]
you can find the code in this repository
if you're interested in working with me
at scalableminds we're looking for
engineers just to help me up outside
thanks
all right so that was jonathan strebel
with his talk um so we still have a few
questions from slido and if we have time
we'll get to the audience so um the
first question is would you advise
storing data in a single file if we
eventually want to spread our
computation over multiple cores
that's a good question so
it depends also on your file system
right i mean if reading from the same
file is not a bottleneck for you
then this might be a good idea because
if you change your parallelization
strategy later and you don't know yet
from which files you will need to read
and you have larger chunks for example
in a later step then you will need to
read from more files again
but if reading from the same file across
different nodes for example is a
bottleneck then you should definitely
consider doing this in different files i
mean that's why there is
chunking and sharding in different
libraries exactly for that reason
all right so the next question is have
you thought about doing all of this in a
database it seems like the data is well
structured
um
yes
actually so we didn't do it in
production i considered this when doing
this talk
and preparing it
so
i think in this special case it's quite
possible but also just loading it in the
database first is quite an overhead
and having a single database where
everybody is writing to first
is just also not that efficient i mean
if you load it into memory once you can
also just do the operations and then
it's done
um with a database you first need to get
the data in and if you have a data
analysis pipeline you do it usually just
once and we don't
do the same statistics agglomeration
multiple times for the same data
so then it doesn't pay off i'd say
all right so that was the slider
questions does the audience have any
questions they want to ask we have time
for one or two
all right then i'll do another slider
question
so
another question is
you mentioned profiling
perform sorry um
performance evaluation at the beginning
so one of the audience asks how do these
performance evaluations compare to
inline magic like line profiler
so
i think
the yuppie i've shown is quite something
like line profiling
so that's really similar
i'm not sure where the big difference
would be to be honest so
pi spy that i've shown is sampling based
so you have a sampling rate
and for example in this case it's
sampled
just 100 times per second and this helps
you to not get too much overhead from
the profiling itself since the just in
regular intervals checks where the code
is
and if it's running for long enough
you'll just get good data
and those line-based ones
just instrument all your code and every
single
call in there will be noted somewhere
and this just takes more time
all right thank you very much
so
that was a great talk and i'd like to
thank you again for the thank you
[Applause]